in the past century we've made massive
leaps in human performance for instance
in swimming the men's 100-meter
freestyle record has improved
twenty-nine percent since 1905 the men
shop would world record is 49 percent
farther now than in 1909 for women the
gains are even greater some women's
field event records have been proved by
more than one hundred percent but the
pace of improvement is slowed
dramatically in the past 20 years we're
not gonna eat slow but we're not getting
faster as fast which raises the question
what are the actual limits of human
performance we were trying to figure out
why records ought to always get better
you think humans are humans why wouldn't
they stay more or less the same it
expanded from humans dogs and horses
because there's lots of data for
instance in horse racing the times in
the Kentucky Derby's haven't gotten any
better since the late 1940s people have
tried to breed faster horses and said
what they're doing is breeding more
fragile horses so they will be that
Secretariat was the fastest horse that
ever is going to be the fastest horse
can't exist human beings are going to
run into the same problem eventually the
horses have now the system as a whole
is bumping up against infamous figuring
out what the limit was was an
interesting application of statistics
most records went back to like the 1920s
so he started in the 1920s and speeds
were fairly low and they increased
increased increased and then start to
sort of level out at some point so it
suggests that that there is some sort of
plateau even though you might not have
reached them what I then did was take
the statistics of extremes which allows
you to think about that variation around
something it's what allowed me to do was
say ok the fastest time every year is
the extreme for the human beings for
that year running say the 400-meter race
and there's some variation from your
year but you can apply the statistics of
extremes to that variation say ok the
distribution looks like this and we can
predict statistically that the biggest
deviation from that trainer everyone get
is such as so that is the maximum around
that unchanging trend in dennys analysis
paula radcliffe's marathon world record
of 2 15 25 it's the closest performance
so far to our physical limits Denny
predicts that the absolute record will
be 2 1458 similar to try to selectively
breed faster human beings and it just
comes down to a muscle power if you've
got a certain amount of mass you have to
accelerate up to that speed
a lot of fast-twitch muscle in the
ability to exert it on a skeleton it's
not going to break when you do it is
what its gonna take to suck that fastest
time of course one spectacular
performance could blow Denny's work out
of the water but if that happens he
claims that he won't mind